Reading more about the Joe Tipens protocol, there is much discussion about the poor bioavailability of Fred Mendezal, and here's an article.
I read that article before, and I just find it funny how, when there's all this evidence from alternative doctors that something is working, they have to go and try to throw a wrench in it.
Fred-ezal is not really water soluble and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Well, I mean, maybe, yeah, I would agree. It's not water soluble, but maybe, you know, if a person is taking, let's say, the normal, initial dose of Ahmed-ezal, 22 milligrams per day, three days on, four days off, maybe it's only, they're only needing 150 milligrams to help kill the cancer.
It's a kind of nonsense about that. I would, I always try to take positives out of the evidence that is, that is, that is laid out.
And taking the positive out of that was that, okay, well, maybe you should eat a fat when you take your Fred-ezal.
Some people have gone even further and tried to mix the Fred-ezal in an oil, like an olive oil or something like that.
And then swallow it in it, kind of making their own liposomal, Fred-ezal, really doesn't work exactly like that. But if you just eat it with a fat, maybe you'll get better absorption of that.
So, it's a fairly inexpensive product, and you certainly, that's maybe, maybe that's why some people go to a higher doses of Ahmed-ezal.
But the argument with that is kind of silly, because you can say that about any drug that's not readily absorbed, how much is the bioavailability of any medication that you're taking, you're only getting a percentage of it, the rest is being deposited in the toilet.
But they don't bash that, I just think it's kind of silly.